RUSSIA, UKRAINE AS BEING THOSE
INVOLVED.
>> AND WE'RE TOLD NOW THAT WE
HAVE VIDEO FROM THE MOMENT THE
PLANE CRASHED.
WE ARE SEEING THIS NOW FOR THE
FIRST TIME.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
WE'LL TRY TO RE-RACK THAT JUST
TO TAKE ANOTHER LOOK.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY VERY FAR IN THE
DISTANCE FROM WHERE THIS VIDEO
WAS.
YOU TONIGHT ACTUALLY, AS FAR AS
WE CAN SEE -- IT DOES SEEM THAT
IT CAME DOWN RELATIVELY IN ONE
AREA, OR AT LEAST THE BIGGEST
PART OF IT SEEMED TO HAVE COME
DOWN IN ONE AREA.
>> WELL, JUDGING FROM THE AMOUNT
OF FLAMES THAT WE SAW AT THE
POINT OF IMPACT, THAT WAS A
LARGE CHUNK PROBABLY, AND THAT
OBVIOUSLY IS FUEL GOING UP WHEN
YOU GET THAT COLOR OF SMOKE.
>> ONE'S TEMPTED TO PAUSE FOR A
MOMENT JUST TO REALIZE THE
ENORMITY AND GRAVITY OF WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT IN THIS.
THE PLANE WOULD HAVE BEEN FULLY
FUELED FOR THE AMSTERDAM TO
KUALA LUMPUR FLIGHT.
THE MISSILE OR WHATEVER HIT IT
CLEARLY DIDN'T DESTROY IT IN
MIDAIR.
IT WAS SUFFICIENT FOR THE TANKS
TO HAVE HIT THE GROUND.
DO JUMP IN, SIR, IF THERE'S MORE
THAT YOU CAN ADD.
AND FOR THE TANKS TO HAVE
EXPLODED ON THE GROUND.
BUT WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT THERE
IS --
>> AND AGAIN, THE QUESTION NOW,
AND WE HAVE HEARD OUR NICK PATON
WALSH REPORTING CONCERNS FROM
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS ABOUT THEIR
ABILITY TO ACTUALLY GET TO THE
CRASH SITE.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY ESSENTIAL THAT
OFFICIALS GET TO THE CRASH SITE
NOT ONLY TO GET THE BLACK BOX,
TO RECOVER ANY OTHER ITEMS, AS
WE SAW WITH THE TWA FLIGHT 800
INVESTIGATION WHICH AGAIN
HAPPENED, THIS IS THE
ANNIVERSARY OF THAT PLANE
CRASHING.
THAT WAS A VERY LENGTHY
INVESTIGATION WHERE THEY
BASICALLY REASSEMBLED THE
AIRCRAFT TO TRY TO DETERMINE
EXACTLY WHAT HAD HAPPENED.
AGAIN, ACCESS TO THIS SITE IS
GOING TO BE